quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj ci siamo trovati
su non fa in one night at flaunt in ogni
caso di volta non riesco a ricordarmi il
nome conto è bello mi hanno dimenticato
momento fosse bello questo concetto
donne dicono anche ragazzi l'ultima
volta non ci sono riuscito perché a
detta di tutti ho incontrato il golden
flauti che frequenterà rissi mo che è
una roba che ti in groppa [ __ ] ci
mancava che io andassi a peccare proprio
quello d'oro massiccio che ti fotte
l'anima cm meraviglioso propria parties
che cazzo è la madonna sono partiti da
un minuto come cazzo è possibile un po
di contegno dio mio santo cioè non è
così eccolo a posto no perché mica non è
positivo pena partiti almeno un attimo
di respiro melo d'arte l'unica cosa che
non devo fare ragazzi e guardare questo
che sta cagando poi quando finisce la
carta igienica ti corre addosso come se
fosse un pezzo di merda devo evitare di
guardarla ogni 5 minuti questo è il
problema va bene allora evito di
guardarlo proprio non mi interessa che
caghi di suo che poi ragazzi c'è anche
il 2 di sta roba fanno fatto sta roba
non oso pensare il 2
ciao sai tua madre di quelle [ __ ]
che forse se le fanno anche i panda non
devo dista avete detto che non devo
distrarmi con il castoro non mi
distraggo col castoro perfetto il mio
gioco preferito e non so se si è notato
mi piace proprio tanto ma cosa stai
facce stai pagando ancora levati dalle
palle
bello questo tizio quando ti attacca che
ti arriva in camera c'è i brufoli non ce
li aveva prima già mangiato nutella o
cosa ma è bello che sei caproni ca ga in
pace per cortesia che ancora non ho
capito no per l'amor di dio
mega party no basta sentite andate a
fare qualcos'altro invece di cagarmi le
palle ok ci siamo a mi fa incazzare che
non è una persona brutta prima di
arrivare davanti alla porta si intende
verso le 4 inizia a perdere perchè sti
maledetti stronzi ti ho visto bastardo
io ho una cagata pazzesca che sto tizio
mi corre incontro se non lo posso vedere
correre mimì mi mette in ansia in una
maniera che non potete capire muli city
il culo con l'asse del cesso non cagarmi
le balle a me grazie io chiudo chiusolo
chiusolo chiusolo chiuso questo
populisti di con questo stronzo cani che
siamo arrivati alle 3 di notte ma e
inizia a spuntare un tizio dal muro e
devo capire qual è
cosa devo fare io costo christian calmi
che sono tutti qua dove flam ti lurido
la guerra che è spuntato un tizio call
motiva ominide pur senza intestino ora
che simpatico te lo giuro
no no no no no non a buongiorno ma
quanto sei bello per ragazzi è spuntata
nella gente bella che non mi interessa
proprio questo sta uscendo dal muro li
morisse la famiglia inizio a
preoccuparmi che poi non posso più
chiudere le porte cinque ore sono cinque
ore che resisto cazzo corri lurido
maledetto stronzo corri buongiorno
[ __ ] è mai accaduto pure il
soffitto perfetto meraviglioso niente da
fare ragazzi come volevasi dimostrare un
gioco di me
l'elefante con la toppa sul culo e
bellissimo sto giocando sto innamorando
pazzamente di file one night ma porca
trono è difficile sto gioco è talmente
difficile da fare che non riescono anche
a pronunciarne il nome bellissimo se n'è
andato
no perché tua madre puzza e quello ha
finito la carta vedete non l'ho guardato
distri non me la sono pagata di strisce
l'ha finita uguale se sei un sex symbol
proprio ti voglio a eber crombie porca
[ __ ] mi sono pagati in mano ero io che
ho per te lo schermo
[ __ ] ma [ __ ] ma [ __ ]
non si può vivere però non sta gente dai
e questo cornello sapere è tanto c'è la
porta chiusa
te lo infili tutto stato un manrovescio
al tizio nel muro porca [ __ ]
certo che potresti mangiare un
pochettino di più ma giusto così
no no no no non l'ho guardato e ho
guardato se era andato kazzo forza
[Applauso]
[ __ ] affanculo timori se la
famiglia a tutti i tuoi fratelli
schifosi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
gesù il gesù verso quest ora qui la
quarta che se un quasi alla fine è stato
molto mi spunta un tizio altissimo ecco
questo alto magro dio mio paziente
stronzi nell'anima cazzo sono tutti è
uno li l'altro non c'è più un altro è
sparito dalla snai sono cinque ore
ragazzine passare sta cosa tipo qualche
secondo ho vinto commessa in the air da
ok fatti vedere fatti vedere forza tu
con la carta igienica incula lo prega
vinci vinci vinci vinci vinci vinci
vinci con sta uscendo dal muro ma non sa
che a squardo brutto che ci arriva mica
sono casa è passata un'ora dalla zucca
zucca tutto tutto quello sta uscendo col
piede aiuto ragazzi cazzo cosa da fare
sono passate 12 ore nella vita reale
possiamo arrivare a 6 grazie molto
gentile ma chi è fucking non ci posso
fottutamente credere
landis lo faccia gazo vita impossibile
starring plant i banchi dei ragazzi the
beaver
justin bieber del regime a redman che si
chiama quest'uomo bello macro gr un fard
e lui brutto bastardo di merda che fa
concorrenza a quello dell'errore almeno
golden flight di perfetto video
bellissimo gioco proprio una merda look
i ragazzi è stato meraviglioso giocare
ragazzi spero che mi sia piaciuto a me
personalmente fa ti schiaccia è stato
carino
vabbè nabaffa però che vi sia piaciuto
cosa sento seguito è piaciuto
astrattamente mi piace al capace di
facebook e come è ridotta la tenda
tiziana un mare di like devono uscire
dallo schermo perché abbiamo finito fi
onenight dio mio buon non ce la faccio a
dirlo ricamo one night fly to one night
plant solo se dovessi discreti non ci
vediamo il prossimo video e da ragazzi
[Musica]
con lo stereo del 1800 a zio come cazzo
stai messo ascoltare
[Musica]